let me just say a quick look for again
further I mean in some ways it's clean I
could have just given you the ends up
well actually you already know the
answer is right um I guess I could have
gone a step further and you remember how
we developed this equation you remember
how we developed that right and that
kind of that doesn't snap in immediately
like most people don't oh yes obviously
it's hard ain't X right like we needed
to workshop that little bit understand
what was going on
now the formation of this is kind of a
critical step and so it is over here now
there's a variety of different pods that
you don't take it from what I can see at
least on your initial drawings
no one's initial drawing is wrong right
because you've identified the critical
thing which is that to get a cone the
area that you're going to rotate around
an axis is a triangle that gives you a
corner a cone I think everyone knows in
order to get a sphere on the area that
you're going to rotate it is uh it's a
circle or a semicircle as you'll see in
a second it actually doesn't matter
which one we do but you've got the UM
you've got a cross-section right okay so
that's good however most of you have
sort of come awry in the algebra that
ensues because some of you picked a
harder version rather than easier one so
he's only I'm gonna go about it
we've got a circle of some kind what is
the very simplest circle you can think
of that we can graph on the Cartesian
the unit circle is the simplest circle
right it's um
x squared plus y squared equals 1 right
that's a great place to start everything
about this is simply okay censoring the
origin radius 1 now I want this to be
somewhat more versatile than a radius of
1 because I want any radius right so you
only have to adjust the equation of the
unit circle a teeny bit in order to get
a ready circle of any radius how do you
adjust it
yeah very good in fact that ah that one
is actually one squared right and that's
what the rainy seasons in order to have
it any arbitrary ready she's changed to
us quick no I haven't been taking
everything eyes like as a function right
X clip less y squared equals Oscar this
is not a function okay but if I want to
be a function for example by just what
the top huh right
what would the equation of this baby
good you can see if you take this
equation up here right you just
rearrange it a little bit to get Y you
take the square root of both sides
you've got a plus place and a negative
case which is on the bottom okay now
that's fine that's what that's the way I
would deal with this however you might
notice right if I ended up taking the
whole thing I mean I do want to speed
off to roll okay there's said the
equation of the whole thing is this no
this actually ends up being very useful
to us because you know what don't you
get a volume right you know what does it
get a volume e our formula is from A to
B on PI 1 squared DX because I'm
choosing to rotate around the x-axis
right hold on Y squared PI Y squared I
have a my square right there
no you're taking square roots or
anything required right so you can see
from that line all I need to do is just
rearrange and it's so slightly to do
that which of course you could have
gotten from that as well but like I mean
it's kind of like yes let's take the
square root and then square it's right
you've got Y squared already you might
as well now because it's a circle with
radius ah right my batteries are
negative off and uh and now I'm ready to
form my integral right I just say the
volume is equal to got my boundaries now
I've got Y squared right there don't
need to square this again that's already
been square what's the what's the period
yeah next one is execute
now by the way at this point at this
point by the way I actually could have
made things a little bit easier for me
the step before because this semicircle
here right
it has symmetry I can take advantage of
right like I could do this rather than
forming this centers wrong I could stay
I'll do it another color I could say
because those two sides are symmetrical
this is the same as double from naught
to R of the same integral right do you
agree with that that would have worked
just fine okay and in fact because this
is zero there that will almost certainly
be easier to evaluate however I'm just
going to follow up with this because
this is the path the majority of you
have taken just so you can see how the
algebra turns out okay I've got my pie
at the front thank you Mark and then I
have time to wait it's actually pretty
simple why you end up getting a whole
bunch of ah cubes you get a cubed at the
front take away a cute on three bays
your upper boundary and then what you
subtract is now just watch out for your
science okay watch out for your sides
you've got minus R cubed at the front
plus R cubed on three because there's
this negative and that negative because
there's three of them so four in total
that's why you're gonna play okay closed
brackets now that looks a little bit
weird maybe if it some of you is not
what you expected some of you would say
like something's wrong right something
is not wrong just be patient with it um
this guy at the front right it's
something to take away a third or
something that's two thirds or something
right here because and this is the whole
even function thing happening right this
is exactly the opposite it's minus 2 R
cubed on three okay so you can take the
double negative here you're gonna get
the four on three that you were looking
for which gives a familiar old formula
for volume
okay yes yep you put these two together
yeah that's fine
you'll get the same thing so if you
wanted to put these two together first
you would get two are huge
then I think you're putting these two
together which would be minus 2 R cubed
on three
I just evaluated this first which maybe
that and evaluated this which gave me
that I evaluated my upper and lower
boundaries together okay but this is the
same thing like two R cubed is six R
cubed on three which is doing four so
it's not complicated once you know the
machinery and how to use it properly how
these are probably by the way is the
critical thing worth pointing out since
this is kind of a new thing for you guys
the volumes by integration not on your
reference sheet right which is just
another reason why it's really important
to wrap your head around how to use
these and how to use them in different
cases